Last spring.
Only one thing seems certain: After a year plus of being socially distance, single people everywhere, were going to hit the streets and the sheets like some mixture of the premenopausal Sex
and the C
ity girls and the randy castaways of Love Island. Everywhere you looked, experts and reporters were predicting a slutty summer, a hot vax summer, an eruption of raw carnal desire not seen since the heyday of the sexual revolution.
There's a bar on every single corner
in New York City.
Not everybody is an alcoholic.
I mean, just because things are
available, people don't change who
they are. And what this pandemic
did was it just made all
these singles grow up.
They are really now looking for
something stable.
I mean, yes, look still counts,
but not the way they did count.
Anthropologist Helen Fisher is the
chief science adviser to the dating
site Match.com, a senior
fellow at the Kinsey Institute
and one of the authors of Singles in
America, an annual survey
of 5'000 representative
people of all genders, races,
ages and sexual orientations.
Now in its 11th year, Singles
in America has charted the growth of
what Fisher calls "slow love",
or an extended vetting process
in which people, especially women,
are far more choosy, deliberate
and intentional in picking romantic
partners. The hot vax summer
didn't happen, says Fisher,
because for decades we've been
trending away from bad boys
and crazy girls and more
toward stable, serious
relationships.
There's less and less sex going
on, and I do think
it's because the rise of
all these people dedicated to their
career. It's amazing how Americans
are so dedicated to their career.
There's many more women in the
workforce.
I'm calling them the new Victorians.
I mean, they have much less sex than
we did in my generation.
Fisher says that, as women have
gained equality
and education in the workplace,
they've started to exercise more
discretion when it comes to pairing
off and whether or not to have
children.
This year in the Singles in America
study, when we asked, Are you
.
We were the picky sex.
The Singles in America survey finds
that men overwhelmingly want a
partner with an equal or superior
career.
That's the so-called "Clooney
Effect," named for the Oscar winning
actor, whose wife Amal is
a highly regarded human rights
lawyer. In other words, a more
libertarian world in which men and
women have more options due to
dating apps and more equality
due to social and economic changes
turns out to be a lot less
libertine.
Women are stuck in the home, men
aren't stuck with being the sole
responsibility for the good economic
health of the family.
We live in a world now where you can
really be who you want
to be. You can jump class, get
yourself an education, move into
the job market at a different level.
I mean, this is all good.
We're living longer.
I mean, we're living longer.
It's a more exciting time than any
time on the planet.